[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva crónica en casa
a esta opción nos ha empujado la
pandemia que está llevando al límite a
la cultura al punto de lanzarse a la
venta de obras ante este dilema se halla
en la royal academy de londres con un
mármol de miguelángel cuyo precio
salvaría del despido a 150 trabajadores
y reduciría en 10 millones de dólares
sus costes anuales hablamos del 40 por
ciento de su personal salvado por el
fondo está ley la única escultura del
artista italiano en reinounido hecha en
1504 al tiempo de su david
si la institución aún no se ha decidido
es porque su venta está el nivel del
sacrilegio para que se hagan una idea
está mal visto y hasta estación hable
que un museo recaude fondos y éstos no
se dedican a comprar otras obras es la
base de la protección del arte no
obstante el museo de brooklyn ha abierto
la veda porque es subastar 12 obras en
christie's o seguir sin liquidez le
duele perder a boteach y ni a este coro
o a donato debate además de lucrecia de
cranach pero la ganancia será para el
cuidado del resto de su colección y los
gastos asociados de sus más de 160 mil
piezas
la excepción de la venta es lo
contemporáneo y gustavo dudamel lo
supera con realidad virtual en sinfonía
el músico y director venezolano se ha
dirigido como cicerone de este proyecto
español que a partir de unos lentes nos
lleva a través y dentro de la música
clásica lo decimos así porque uno puede
hacer parte de la orquesta mahler
chamber a la que dirige para esta
ocasión encarnando a beethoven o ir
hasta el taller de un luthier y entrar
en un violín en un viaje que llega hasta
la galaxia como dicen sus creadores es
como estar en una caja de música que va
desde el sonido más natural hasta el
instrumento que produce otras notas es
una nueva llave de abrir una puerta para
poder
para que puedan entrar nuevas
generaciones tratamos de luchar de que
las nuevas generaciones no vean la
música como algo la música clásica sobre
todo clásica como algo antiguo como algo
que al cual no podemos tener acceso es
de mis padres de mi abuelo o es de otra
generación sino que forma parte y tiene
una temporalidad que vive siempre ya
desde el séptimo arte un cine que
obsesiona o se ignora y como no su firma
es la de miranda july que vuelve tras
diez años con callejones a priori nadie
mejor que ella para abordar este
desconcierto cobit al que suma una
familia de estafadores su existencia es
como la de un clan surrealista y raro en
el cual la hija o el dolió de 26 años
debe tomar relevo la cuestión es por
dónde agarrar un hogar que es una
oficina en la que entran pompas de jabón
de una fábrica y del que poco afecto ha
recibido por ello dolió es común
eduardo manostijeras de voz grave cuya
rutina cambia con el encuentro de una
joven extrovertida una forma de
embellecer y de construir diálogos e
imágenes que de nuevo es sólo firma de
jolie
de verdad
[Música]
pero tienes
firma y criatura de nancy springer es en
hola holmes contar apellido y publicidad
que ha hecho un etf leaks lo que
sorprende este estreno pero tras la
hermana no oficial de microsoft y
sherlock hay un universo potente y
político para empezar la cinta es fruto
de la biografía de springer que durante
años sufrió una vida doméstica y de
prototipo tras esa liberación escribió
seis libros sobre no la que si bien no
responden al legado holmes son aventuras
que lo enriquecen desde un vínculo madre
e hija que se trunca cuando la primera
desaparece este hecho vivido por
springer se da en la lucha del voto
femenino y hacia esa independencia se
dirige en hola a don es decir sola
mientras la busca resolviendo además el
caso de un joven vizconde decisivo para
esa ley es que mejor que mil y bobby
braun para este rol que da un puntapié a
la sociedad sin contar que su familia
está detrás de este gran proyecto que
apunta a salvar
x
nunca me he matado
septiembre se despide con la vitalidad
de en ola mientras octubre nos recibe
con discos uno esperado por pospuesto es
el tercero del británico sam schmidt iba
a llamarse to die for pero el hobbit
cambio s morir por el amor que fluye
love cops lo único improvisado de un
trabajo de dos años con temas que son
retazos de historias esta es un no al
amor codicioso
[Música]
sí
otro que llega es go el debut de la
congoleña belga luc en de yakuza
confirmación de su estética
coreografiada y poética y de un rap que
es a la vez delicado y eléctrico tras él
está el guincho productor de rosalía
[Música]
el último que es nuestro cierre se
definen diciendo a lija puede que sea el
séptimo pero es el recorrido de 20 años
siendo alícia keys en consecuencia es
con el que más se identifica encarnando
sonidos variados y una mirada sobre la
brutalidad policial su troupe without
love es un temazo cuídense y muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]